you might be using one of the most
powerful language learning tools every
single day
and you don't even know it that tool
netflix
hi my name is luca from lucca
lamprello.com and today i'm going to
show you
how you can use the world famous content
streaming platform netflix
to learn foreign languages nowadays the
offering on netflix
is huge you have all sorts of movies tv
series documentaries you name it
so if you're using netflix to learn a
foreign language what show should you
watch
well my take is that you should always
watch enjoyable content in other words
content that you find interesting and
entertaining
i for one like watching tv series or
documentaries one of the reasons why i
usually watch
these instead of movies is because
they're easier to watch
in short bursts i watch netflix on my
computer which can be distracting so
watching shorter length
content is great for staying focused and
avoiding the urge to browse the internet
or social media movies are usually from
one to two hours in length and with all
that time needed to focus
it's much easier to get distracted okay
let's say you have decided that you like
to watch tv series for language learning
let's say you're learning french great
well then
french tv series it is well not so fast
while watching french tv series might
seem like the most natural choice the
types of shows you should watch
really depend on your level if your
level is b2 or more i definitely go for
an authentic show in that language
if your level is lower you might opt for
something different
instead what about taking a show you've
already seen in your native language
and watching a version dubbed in your
target language
this is useful because being already
familiar with the show's content will
greatly
facilitate your ability to understand it
in another language
and on top of that dubbers tend to speak
very clearly and articulately
the only downside is that dubbed voices
can seem a little bit artificial since
onset
actors don't usually speak like
professional dubbers do however that's a
price you must be willing to pay
if you want to start using netflix
content in your target language
especially if you're not at an advanced
level so
you might want to start watching shows
you already know and which are dubbed
and then moved to more authentic
material when you reach a higher level
the ultimate goal is to watch some
authentic content with authentic
language so always keep that in mind as
you choose
what to watch okay now you've decided
which kinds of shows you want to watch
let's say you chose a tv series a common
question to get is
should i use subtitles and if so which
ones
well first things first i will tell you
that i've had many students confess that
they feel like using subtitles is
like cheating when i hear that my
reaction is always the same
why do you feel that way subtitles are
an amazing tool
to help you understand content and
reinforce
your listening comprehension they should
always be an option for you
if you're learning a foreign language
now on to the second question
should you put these subtitles in your
target language or native language
and once again it depends on your level
if you've learned the language before
you might have noticed that sometimes
having subtitles in your native language
is more beneficial than having them in
your target language this is
practically true when your level is
still not that high
let's say below b1 but once you get more
and more familiar with the language you
might want to use subtitles directly in
your target language and there's a third
possibility
which i'll tell you about in a moment so
keep watching
have you ever heard of the paradox of
choice
it's the paradox that occurs when we've
given a lot of options
prior to making a decision the more
options we have
the harder it is to actually make a
choice
it seems like nonsense but it makes
perfect sense
when you fire up netflix for the first
time and not just the first time
you might be 100 ready to watch
something but you have so many things
you could watch
that after spending ages searching
through the catalog you end up watching
nothing
seriously this happens to me a lot or at
least it did
before i came up with a tip i'm about to
share i would turn on my computer
pick a show stop pick another show go
back to the main page
and then do it all again and pretty soon
i've accomplished nothing
and all i feel ready to do is go to
sleep pretty
unproductive especially when i wanted to
use my watching time to get listening
practice
in one of my languages here's what you
need to do to avoid this trap
decide what you want to watch well in
advance of the time
you actually sit down and watch it
it is that simple in the morning when
your mind is fresh
maybe at work take some five ten minutes
to pick a movie or show to watch that
evening
and once you've decided write it down on
a post-it or add it to your google
calendar
any visual cue or reminder goes and then
stick to the plan you can even open
netflix
and bookmark the url of whatever you're
going to watch so that
when the fateful moment comes you're
ready to get started at a click of your
mouse
problem solved as far as i'm concerned i
know that every friday night if i'm
staying at home
i watch something on netflix so i
already know that
around 9 pm i will watch one tv show of
around 45 minutes
and i've already decided well in advance
what the show is going to be
i've even got my pick for next week
already figured out tv show called
quicksand
a lot of people tend to watch netflix at
night or after work
it's what we do to relax and get the
most enjoyment
out of our free time for that reason we
throw netflix
on when we're sprawled out on our bed or
a couch
and we just lay there and watch whatever
we watch
and that's all good if all you're using
netflix for
is relaxation but if you're using
netflix to learn a language you might
want to employ different watching
strategies depending on the kind of
value you want to get
from your watching time there are
different ways to engage in netflix
watching
ranging from the totally passive to the
extremely proactive
when you watch passively you're just
watching the show letting it wash over
you
just you and your show nothing else when
you watch actively
things are completely different you're
sitting upright
focused pen or pencil in hand and when
you hear a word you want to remember or
look up
you pause the show and you write it down
you're not just watching the show you're
mining it
for new words and sentences to use if
you're wondering which one is best
my answer is both passive immersion is
easier
and requires less effort while proactive
immersion is rewarding and effective but
it's also tougher to do especially after
a long day at work
every time you use netflix for active
watching you should always be in the
habit of
writing down words and sentences to save
for later learning
this helps focus your attention and will
help route those new vocab items into
your episodic memory not only that but
the simple truth is this
the more you focus the more details you
see and the more details you can absorb
the more you will learn there are a
number of cool ways to which you can say
words and sentences for later take for
example a popular chrome extension
called
learning languages with netflix this
extension allows you to organize
on-screen subtitles in various different
arrangements and language combinations
for example target language subtitles
above native language subtitles
not to mention that it has some amazing
features to make the experience of
saving words 10 times
more convenient and fun than it would be
otherwise
please check my video demonstration on
how to use that and you will find all
the information in the description box
as usual on how to watch it with this
nice piece of software you can quickly
save words on the fly
and then review them later i now use
learning languages with netflix
alongside physical notebooks in which i
write down
all the new words and phrases i learned
that reminds me
no matter what strategy you use to save
new vocab
make sure to never ever write down
single words
that's a capital sin in vocab
acquisition single words have no context
and without context
most words are meaningless that being
said
you should also avoid writing down
entire sentences too if you're in the
middle of watching something it's
annoying to have to
hit pause just to write down an entire
sentence
and even if you can save them with a
click of your mouse you might get into
the
bad habit of saving everything which can
ultimately be
a little bit overwhelming a simple
solution is to aim for something in
between
only write down short fragments of
sentences
as you watch a fragment can vary in size
but
should be the smallest portion of a
sentence that is worth remembering for
example if you stumble upon a noun you
don't know you might want to at least
write down which verb it was used with
if it's a verb you might want to add the
accompanying preposition and
or an object there are a few examples
that i have provided in the article
associated with this video so
again don't forget to check it out all
the info is again in the description box
getting exposed to words is fantastic
it's great and saving words on the fly
is
even better but unfortunately those
simple actions
are not enough to commit information to
long-term memory
i suggest that you get into the habit of
reviewing your words and fragments
within one week of your writing them
down
you can do this in a text file on your
computer or in a physical notebook
the means of recording your fragments
does not matter
as long as they are in a location that
is easily accessible for review
personally i love carrying around small
notebooks that i can flip through on the
fly
and review what i've recently learned if
there is one advantage to watching a
movie or tv show
it is that you can see the full scope of
human
communication with pure audio you cannot
tell how a person is using his face or
body
to communicate when you use netflix for
language learning
make sure you pay attention to people's
faces
body language and hand gestures facial
features and cold speed gestures
are part of the fundamental
communication code of each language
if you pay close attention you will see
how certain emotions are conveying
through recurring gestures
actions and reactions hand and arm
movements and so on speaking language is
not just a matter of uttering sounds
it's a way to live and navigate in this
world and you can learn a lot from
observing human beings interact
within the rules of their cultural and
linguistic code so
here's the recap first decide the kind
of material you want to consume
always choose content that is
interesting to you and that works well
with the limits of your attention span
start with dubbed content and then move
gradually towards authentic movies and
tv shows as you gain more experience
always make sure that you have subtitles
at least in your target language
alternate between passive and proactive
listening and when you do the latter
make sure you record or write words for
safe keeping
and keep reviewing them regularly pay
attention to the holistic style of
communication
that unfolds in a show particularly
facial features
and body language so there you have it
you've got everything you need to start
binge watching
target language shows on netflix but
before you go don't forget to subscribe
and check all the extra info i've left
for you down
in the description box if you click the
link to the blog you'll find an in-depth
article with even more resources
as well as a video demonstration on how
to use the language
learning with netflix chrome extension
as always
thanks for watching i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
you